so why do some businesses and YouTube
channels fail while others succeed in
this video I'm gonna be sharing five
proven reasons that we can identify so
that we can also avoid so we can
actually break through and get results
with our YouTube channels but hey if
we're just meeting my name is Sean
kennel I'm the co author of the
best-selling book YouTube secrets and
recently over on our channel think media
on YouTube we just crossed 1 million
subscribers it's been pretty crazy we've
grown multiple YouTube channels over a
hundred thousand and just recently got
that plaque and plus on another project
I've done I've interviewed a man over
150 different YouTube business owners
entrepreneurs and YouTube creators
learning why they've succeeded in why
they failed and seen a lot of lessons on
the journey and I've been trying to kind
of answer that question man what are the
elements that lead to success or kind of
more importantly what are the elements
that lead to failure and how can we
avoid those but if you're just joining
for this weekly think Q&A show that
we're doing in about 10 to 15 minutes
we're gonna get into your questions and
I have to think media team joining me
Heather tourist Melissa Caputo but at
the beginning we like to give you some
tangible actionable value that you can
apply to get more results on your
channel so no matter where you're
watching this smash the like button drop
a comment below as far as where you're
watching and let's get into this and I
have to say that this was inspired by an
article by Eric Wagner who's a serial
entrepreneur he's been a serial
entrepreneur for 30 years and on Forbes
he wrote an article about five reasons
why eight out of ten businesses fail now
according to Bloomberg eight out of ten
entrepreneurs that start a business fail
within the first 18 months a whopping
80% crash and burn and I was inspired
because I thought man this is true for
YouTube as well like a lot of people who
start a YouTube channel don't
necessarily reach success why is that
and as I was reading this I thought man
these these reasons have a lot of
correlation to them and before we get
into the five reasons let me just
clarify
think one of the first big reasons that
I think that YouTube channels fail is
actually because they don't think like a
business you know Sean why are you
correlating reasons why businesses
failed to our YouTube channels fail
because I actually think it's kind of
one in the same thing and you know here
on the think marketing YouTube channel
or if you're watching this on Facebook
or catching the replay that's one of our
passions is to help business minded
content creators really achieve success
or help entrepreneurs leverage YouTube
to grow their business I think you have
to be thinking like a business owner I
think that's a mistake and a reason
people fail because they think man I
just want to share my message with the
world I just want to be creative they
don't think think about the economic
viability of their YouTube channel of
what it is that they're doing and sure
enough when it turns out not to be
viable or there's not enough money for
the mission and money runs out or
there's not a proven path to
monetization well then it's hard to
sustain the mission if you don't have
practical business printed principles
built around your channel and that's
part of our passion so as we get into
these kind of five reasons I hope you
stay connected here on you know wherever
you're watching this subscribe hit the
like on the page you know jump on our
email list or whatever it is so you can
stay connected to us because we're here
to equip you with the necessary skills
you know YouTube strategies and really
the back end because YouTube's kind of
just the tip of the iceberg if you've
seen that iceberg picture it's like
underneath it is like business acumen
strategy like marketing you know all
those other skillsets and so in a lot of
ways you know jay-z put it this way I'm
not a businessman I'm a business man
right you're not a business woman you're
a business woman like you are a business
as a YouTube creator you got to be
thinking man how am I gonna fund this
thing I'm gonna market this thing what
sales what's promotion you know what is
HR and and those might not be things we
normally think of as creators but it is
very very important if we want to
succeed on YouTube in the long term in
my opinion so let me know do you already
think about
yourself as a business do you have a
clear business plan or what is your
niche or what's your YouTube channel all
about like do you help a particular
people achieve a certain result you know
entrepreneurs help people solve problems
for a profit
and as we get into these reasons it
makes me think of why you're needed more
now than ever before because there's so
many problems in the world I'm
empathetic and we recognize that we're
going through a lot of important things
right now a lot of a spotlight is being
shined on black lives matter and we
think that's so important right now and
such an important conversation of the
times and so that's happening it's very
emotional overwhelming and so many
different people are involved in that
and we're also going through a pandemic
and there's all those kinds of things
there's economic disruption right now
and so if anything you know we think
that we need to be navigating with more
empathy and more grace than ever before
as business owners as content creators
we believe your message matters and we
believe that now's the time to be
speaking hope to be speaking justice to
be speaking powerful messages to be
building businesses to be solving
problems to be helping people save money
make money lose weight be entertained
gain muscle do all the things reduce
stress and burnout find a good job pivot
their career so many different things so
what is it that you help people with
what problem do you help people solve
because it's the time for
Entrepreneurship it's the time for small
business because we solve problems and
there's a lot of problems in the world
and that's what today's episode is all
about but specifically how do we succeed
on YouTube and why do so many fail on
YouTube reason number one coming from
this article and I linked it in the
description below is not really being in
touch with customers through deep
dialogue okay so why do YouTube channels
fail this is why businesses fail why
YouTube channels fail not actually being
in touch with customers through deep
dialogue where you go I don't even think
I have customers well maybe that's why
your channels failing who is your target
audience and do you
really understand listen their pain
points the words they use the phrases
they search the things that are looking
for you no have you ever been to a
business and you thought man I just
didn't really connect with them they
seemed out of touch like I walked in
they didn't even greet me I was looking
around like do they want to make sales
you know it was kind of funny because
some places are requiring face masks
even if they aren't required during this
pandemic and we've been to a couple we
went to some boutiques my wife Sonya and
I in Utah and we went into one where
they had a hand sanitizer station and a
thing full of face masks a box of a
couple hundred face masks cost ten bucks
these business owners were providing
them for us well she told me a story
about going to California with her
friend Megan and Sarah and one she
wanted to go to a bookstore she walked
up shoot I forgot my face mask they want
to let her in right no face mask they
wouldn't let her in so she then came
back later to see if they were still
open with her face mask and they had
closed that like five or something not
even six and I thought man what a missed
opportunity by that business owner
because dude put out a box of 200 face
masks for nine bucks like she was about
to spend money in your store like why
aren't you doing everything possible to
make sure customers can reach you
understand you figure you out one of the
reasons why YouTube channels fail is
being out of touch with the viewer
you know Benji Travis from video
influencers got to talk to Gary
Vaynerchuk he said the number one
mistake that YouTube channels make is
they're making selfish content they're
making content for themselves they don't
think about the audience first so are
you out of touch with your target
audience do you know there are pains
their feelings their emotions what
they're going through and for business
owners that are connected to us as well
this is so powerful isn't it come on hit
like if you're getting value so so get
in touch and what's the way to do that
so how do you fix that have
conversations ask more questions on your
community tab ask more questions on
Twitter get on the phone what like get
on a zoom call what do you mean
invite if twenty-five people watch
youtube-channel invite them to just do
like a 30-minute hang out with you I'm
serious why because when you start
actually hearing their language what
they're saying their questions their
pain points then you actually start
getting more empathetic and more
connected and therefore you can have
success and stop being out of touch and
therefore accelerating failure okay
reason number two no real
differentiation in the market now we
talk about this all the time here's why
businesses fail YouTube channels fail
how are you different
the reason businesses fail YouTube
channels fail is they're not really
different from the other offerings in
the market so a couple ways to fix this
different is better than better Sally
hogshead said that how can you be
different not better than the
competition how can you bring a unique
spin to something that already feels
crowded how can you amplify your
difference whether that's in your
messaging whether that's in your
positioning whether that's in the niche
you choose or the unique aspect you put
on the niche you can sometimes be
different in your niche or be different
in your niche audience what do I mean
you could say like we help you with
YouTube tips and we help you build your
business using online video and we help
purpose-driven entrepreneurs it's kind
of like our passion is really helping
people that are mission driven hard
driven faith driven entrepreneurs and
and of course all kinds of people
connect with our community but that's
sort of like our our focus now there are
some people that maybe could help
millennial female moms learn how to use
social media to create side income
that's like oh that's a much different
message than you just heard from me plus
it'd be a little bit weird if I was like
I'm here to help moms come on I help
millennial moms I mean I guess I could
but you might be like I don't know if
you seem why cuz a lot of times you're
gonna help people that actually look
like you or have been through what
you've been through or that you've done
it yourself I can't talk about the
plight of a millennial mom very
articulately because it's not been up
have really what personally walked makes
sense so you might do the same thing you
think the world's so crowded but what's
nice about what you do is the market the
target audience you reach out to hey
this is why businesses fail well we
don't just if you're just another just
another coffee company just another
Fitness person just another tech channel
you got to find out a way to be
different that's reason number two hit
like if you're getting value and today's
stream is brought to you also by our
YouTube web class which will actually
help you saw solve all five of these
reasons YouTube channels fail if you
want to learn more about that it's a
tube masterclass com and I'll tell you a
little bit more about that in a second
and then of course we have Q&A coming up
a reason number three failure to
communicate value propositions in a
clear concise and compelling fashion
this is why YouTube channels fail fail
listen hey by the way these are coming
out of Eric Wagner's article a 30 years
serial entrepreneur written in Forbes
and I'm like dude you're like
Nostradamus of why YouTube channels are
failing bro he's talking about
businesses I'm like this is exactly
YouTube like if you aren't communicate
what is your value proposition for your
channel post in the comments what's your
value proposition failure to communicate
it are you communicating it but are you
commuting it listen in a clear concise
and compelling fashion so if you just
have a value proposition well that's
kind of good but but just having one
doesn't mean it's good right is it clear
is it concise if it's kind of long or
clunky or doesn't really make sense but
it also should be compelling does it
light up the listener does that listener
say oh man I want I want help with that
I want to do that like again it's not
enough to just have one
I think compelling is a key word there
and so knowing that you have a different
like what is your value proposition if
your customers are unclear about who you
are and what value you bring to them
then you're going to lose if your target
isn't really sure but your YouTube
channel is about be concise you don't
want it to go on and on how can you have
a really compelling and punchy message
and and then how can you get people to
take action to light up a passion within
them here's a tip you don't want to
light a passion in everybody remember if
you try and reach everybody you end up
reaching nobody so it's all about again
I help single Pellini ol moms create
side income with social media like
that's not gonna light a fire and
everybody but a single millennial mom's
gonna be like man I need some side
income and I would love to get into
social media it's gonna spark a fire in
a particular group of people right a
particular audience so how can you
strengthen your value proposition
clarify your YouTube channel and our
free masterclass link in the description
and if you're watching this on Facebook
our team will drop a link in the
comments or you just go to think master
class com that's one of our biggest
passions we're gonna be get crystal
clear on the kinds of videos that you
should make the kind of you know how to
position your YouTube channel and create
the right content and do YouTube right
and man clarity is power
all right reason number four leadership
breakdown at the top yes founder
dysfunction so you see this all the time
in the media right off the deep-end goes
another athlete you know somebody self
sabotages like a Lance Armstrong Mike
Tyson Aaron Hernandez like different
people because they were having success
and they started making poor decisions
so actually if you're just starting this
is a challenge but this is also what can
come later after massive success I
actually heard a preacher say one time
that said dealing with failure people
think dealing with failures hard and
this might feel lack of empathy but like
he said you think dealing with failures
hard tried dealing with success I've
seen people get successful and get crazy
I've seen people get successful blow up
their life and one of our passions here
at think media in our company is not
just helping 10,000 Purpose Driven
entrepreneurs create a full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the
with online video but also helping them
sustain that success through the
principles and a lifestyle that will
last
basically success without losing your
soul because what can happen is you
start getting successful you start
getting different pressures or you start
you're doing a side hustle and you're
adding on YouTube and you're adding all
these different things and it can add
extra pressure and stress to your life
and it can affect all areas so there's
something about not breaking down and so
the two sides of this tip would be on
the one hand if you want your YouTube
channel to grow and you're just starting
you need to grow leadership breakdown if
we're honest we are the bottleneck
that's what extreme ownership is like I
got to take responsibility for
everything in my life it's all my fault
like if I want my marriage to get
stronger by the way you might be like
well no actually marriage is 50/50 now
in my opinion it's a hundred a hundred
therefore it's a hundred if the other
person zero because you made a
commitment and so extreme ownership is
saying dude it's all my fault like if my
youtube channel is not growing it's not
the algorithms fault it's my fault if my
youtube channel is not growing I need to
learn a new skill I need to get better
at thumbnails I need to get maybe better
I just clearer idea change my niche
update like I need to grow as a leader
and I've learned this that if you grow
your business grows if you grow your
YouTube channel grows if you get better
and strengthen your communication skills
your marketing skills your business
skills your leadership skills your
teamwork skills I know it's a lot but
also think about us and the audacity
that we have to be able to create
content from home or from an office and
reach people on the internet and create
passive income and sell our products and
services in a very competitive world
with a lot of people like you got to
work to to take your spot and here's the
cool good news if you're intentional and
you're focused and you continue to
commit to growth one of our favorite
authors here to think media is John
Maxwell and he wrote the irrefutable
laws of growth that life is less
about even a destination and it's about
just a commitment to growth a commitment
to continue to get one percent better
and we better get better today because
here's the here's the problem my friend
I actually worry about this I pray about
this I'm like I don't only want to help
you be successful I don't want you to
blow your life up once you are like for
real like I want you to not just have
success but I want you to be successful
in five years in seven years I don't
just want you to get money you like come
on Sean I'm trying to like get some bank
going some banker like I want to get the
bag cool but like I want you to keep the
bag you've seen lottery winners like
they just they get they get they win
their lottery and they blow their life
up or they just spend all the money
leadership breakdown at the top you
study Silicon Valley you study startups
people have initial success and
sometimes they self implode so founder
dysfunction what's the solution we got
to realize that like this is your baby
you're the founder this is you're the
leader you got a level up your skills so
let me ask you this what's one skill you
need to grow in what's one skill you
need to develop what's one maybe area of
a weakness that could be a vulnerability
one of the best ways to stay in business
is to try and put yourself out of
business
like I like to ask what is my greatest
vulnerability personally and alright
I've had to fight through a lot of
things in my personal life I've had to
fight through things in our marriage
we've gone through counselling we've
gone through things to where we would
strengthen because look I've learned
that man I believe my marriage is
interconnected to my business like my
marriage is blowing up like I'm not as
effective as a leader you know if my
personal life I've had to deal with I
hit it I hit a pace of pressure where my
personal health had a lot of weaknesses
so I had to start addressing some of
those and so it could be habits it could
be mindsets it could be a lot of things
was just one thing when we actually if
were face the fact that Yemen founder
dysfunction who's the founder of your
YouTube channel you whose fault to visit
succeeds or fails your mom's I know it's
probably her fault like I'm the way she
raised you come on like we got to take
responsibility for our YouTube channel
hit like if you're getting value we got
the final tip
then we're gonna get into your questions
in just a second and the way we love to
do questions too is throw four question
marks before after whether you're
watching this on a replay or live on
Facebook or YouTube put four questions
up your question and we can talk about
anything on these q and A's but if it's
actually about these principles we'd
love that I'd love to help and we're
gonna have Heather and Mel on here in
just a second but number five this is
huge y'all inability to nail a
profitable business model with proven
revenue streams yeah so if you're going
into your YouTube channel and I ask you
the question what's your business model
for your YouTube channel
well I'm not sure okay well what's like
your revenue streams and and how are
they going to be profitable like break
it down for me like you may not have the
views yet or the subscribers yet but
like play out the whole plan for me like
provided next month and in three months
and in six months if this thing is kind
of growing at the current pace even if
you're getting like if you're gonna buy
twenty subscribers now okay cool well
you're gonna have twenty months and then
it'll probably go up a little bit so
how's this all gonna break down what's
your business model what are your
revenue streams a lot of people I talk
to they're like I'm not really sure I
just I mean I want to just like shoot
videos like put my passion out there or
like I don't really know how this
connects to my business might be a
reason why the channel is not working or
it's not successful furthermore it's
definitely the reason why I think a lot
of people burn out on YouTube and I
don't mean from like overworking or I
don't mean from you know any kind of
like emotional pressure or haters in the
comments I think that when people don't
focus enough on the practicality of
money money is needed to sustain the
mission a lot of people get
uncomfortable with money they have money
mindsets they got to deal with but like
money's needed to sustain the mission a
profitable business model is so that you
aren't just in business today it's so
you're in business tomorrow and I've
seen so many people come and go in this
space I've shown I've seen so many
people not be able to last because they
actually don't have a consistently
profitable business model connected to
their YouTube channel with consistently
profitable revenue streams that are set
up to sustain
past having to work 24/7 to just keep
the thing afloat um there's something
too practical about it and if you want
help with that specifically that's
actually exactly what our free youtube
class is all about and so if you go to
think master class comm if you want more
help with that specific tip that's where
we'll go more into that in talking about
how to actually keep your revenue
streams consistent by following our
system of getting views 24/7 on YouTube
connected to profitable revenue streams
and what the best revenue streams are I
mean you'll learn a couple different
ways to earn a thousand dollars on
YouTube that could scale to ten ten
thousand hundred thousand whatever you
want to do and again it's totally free
at the end of that class we talked about
our our signature program called video
ranking Academy and that's that's just
kind of the process you basically get
like one hour of a premium module of our
signature course entirely for free and
so many people have taken just that and
gotten like sick results but if you want
to check that out and you haven't seen
it yet think master class comm link in
the description below and then also at
the end you'll learn more if you kind of
want to go to the next step because
here's the good news these are reasons
why people fail and I'd like to know
which one of these reasons stood out to
you the most is it is it because just
recapping as we get into Q a not really
being in touch with your customers could
you get in touch with your target
audience better let me know in the
comments get clear on who your audience
is is it not really being different the
market not knowing your difference and
identifying your difference reason
number two is it reason number three
failing to communicate your value
proposition maybe not even having a
value proposition in a clear concise and
compelling fashion number for leadership
breakdown at the top man sometimes we
got to deal with our own BS right our
own belief system probably the other BS
to some of the issues in our life we
have to grow like if you want your
YouTube channel to grow you got to grow
and then number five inability to nail a
profitable business model with proven
revenue streams
I believe my friends that you can grow
in all these areas fix these and succeed
massively on YouTube and there's never
been a more important
one out of two people on planet earth
alive people not people connected to the
Internet
I think there's 60% of the planets on
the internet now and 50% of the planets
on social media that's the official
stats from HootSuite so one out of two
people in the world are on on the
Internet
2 billion monthly active people are on
YouTube and so I don't care who you are
like if you want to grow a church a
non-profit a business a personal brand
you're an author you're a speaker you
gotta be on YouTube it is irresponsible
not to be building your influence on
YouTube and when you have the right
system and the right strategies or by
the way like even if we never see each
other again I need you to go all-in on
YouTube just out of love and empathy for
you to be like please invest in YouTube
because it's a massively smart
investment in terms of we need online
offers we need to buy be diversified we
got a pivot during the pandemic and we
don't know what the future is gonna hold
but if you're building an online brand
and online influence and online
Authority in an online community and a
thousand true fans this is good ground
to be investing in and we're here to
help as well and so check out resources
in the description below we are going to
jump into your questions in just a
second and then don't miss the free
master class we take that down actually
so we update it from time to time and
it's not always available so watch it
before we take it down think master
class calm and we're gonna jump into
your questions get them in for question
marks in just a second and also growth
video lines coming up and so check out
this quick video and we'll be doing your
questions in just a second 65% of people
use YouTube to help them solve a problem
but when I think about this here's what
question all of us need to answer what
problem do you solve you got to know
that and when you know that people are
going to the internet they go to Google
they go to YouTube to help solve the
problem
you need to be showing up with those
answers
[Music]
Wow grow a video live 20 20 I hope you
can make it and it's virtual so matter
where you are in the world you can be a
part of that now actually listen grow a
video live calm couple different you can
actually be a part of the conference for
as little as $97 but if you haven't
heard that we also give away two free
tickets right now with our signature
program called video ranking Academy you
may just want to check that out directly
because it's probably the best what is
the best like bundle of training I saw a
question how do I get clear my value
proposition we we have a whole clarity
boot blueprint inside a video ranking
Academy go for you alive all the guest
speakers and all that training plus
everything anyways if you want to learn
about that there's actually the website
is start VR a.com but just grow a video
live if you want to learn more about
that growth video live calm and I'm
excited because I've got the chief
operating officer of think media here
with me today Heather tourists she's a
massive clarity coach so we'd actually
love to help why we're here first a few
minutes of Q&A and she is the host of
the think marketing podcast and of
course you've seen her I'm sure or maybe
you haven't because you might be brand
new let me know how long you been
connected to our community and tell us
in the comments section and we also have
Melissa Caputo who is our marketing
director here at think media does a lot
of social media a wizard at or a wizard
dress is that what it is there's a lot
of social media email marketing
copywriting also helps a lot of
entrepreneurs and business owners
clarify their message and their
marketing and so how's it going Heather
and Mel let me know Heather man the chat
was on fire Shawn there were so many
great questions coming in I think people
were really illuminated to the idea that
YouTube really is a business model and
those five reasons I mean make sure you
wrote those down and go back if you
didn't get all five of them because that
is a business blueprint of success like
you solve those five things and you will
see success on YouTube and I'm excited
to get into some Q&A but Melissa what
about you and
you think about that training yeah I
love the rapid fire hitting those points
and everyone's like I need to learn more
about this I need to learn more about
this and I think it's so good to just
introduce a lot of these concepts and
you know a lot of us just didn't even
realize that we needed to go deeper into
them and so I think that is a great
jumping-off point we have some great
questions coming up well I'm excited Mel
let's get into some questions but Shawn
are you seeing this people have been
here someone just just discovered us
someone's been here air he's been here
since early 2019 Mike's been here for
two years JB he's been here for five
years we've got someone since March I
mean it's amazing to see the think
community here live with us today
yeah massive love and thank you so much
for being here we're grateful if we're
just connected or for those that have
been here since the beginning hit the
like button if you've been getting value
out of today and Mel what is the first
question yeah you kind of already
touched on this Shawn but Katherine is
wondering about value proposition so how
can we figure out what our value
proposition is can you just answer that
for us again Shawn how we can go deeper
on that yeah I actually want to kick it
to Heather for this cuz she's a massive
person that's great at helping people
get clarity so Heather what would you
say in helping clarify value proposition
yeah I think when you think about value
proposition it is really what makes like
what is it that you are specifically
going to deliver so when I think about
think media let's take think media for
an example so think media the YouTube
channel is a tech channel I mean we
review cameras and gear and we teach
people but at the same time we're not
doing all tech right we are very
specific that our value proposition is
to help people who want to understand
YouTube and online video we're not
reviewing the best I can't even come up
with some shot I don't even know cameras
but we're not reviewing the black magics
that are creating cinematic photography
and videography we're not doing every
smartphone that comes out we are very
specific to a few different types of
products that we know are great for
creators so when we think about what's
the value that we bring we're doing
things like that we're
we are doing videos that are helping
people understand that they need a
flip-out screen on their camera you
would only need that if you're a creator
and you're gonna be making videos about
yourself so that's one way when I think
about my channel right here this is my
home school channel the value
proposition that I'm bringing is I'm
helping new home school moms learn what
to do I'm basically just really helping
that new home school mom I'm not a
veteran homeschool mom of 20 years
I'm definitely versed in what I know but
my value is really helping like fifth
grade and under that's where I really
want to bring so how do you discover
your value proposition I would decide
who would be your ideal client and what
would you help them with I think what's
difficult is when you get into a new
space and you're like well I mean I can
kind of do everything I mean I can I can
be a graphic designer I can build with
some websites I know how to do Facebook
guides I've also understand marketing
and copywriting no one would hire you
because they're like no I need a
specialist I need someone that I know
does X Y & Z and so when I say you know
I help people with organic and paid
traffic through video you know what I do
that's what I help people do and so when
you think about how do I get my own
value proposition how are you going to
deliver value and what is that for that
person I don't help people learn how to
do Google Ads I know how to do Google
Ads but that's not the value that I'm
bringing so how do you discover your
value proposition is figuring out who do
you serve and how do you serve them and
being really specific on what you don't
do I think that's a big thing like write
a list of the things you know how to do
and then what do you want to be known
for what is that value that you want to
be able to bring and that's just giving
you a little bit but Catherine we go
deeper into this kind of topic inside of
our inner circle program which is our
monthly group coaching and that's a
topic that we cover deeper inside there
so if you're interested in that you can
go to think inner circle comm and get
more info on that topic and things
Heather I think that definition is
really helpful for a lot of people and
so now we have people dropping their
value propositions in the chat
one person is Wendy and she's saying
that her value proposition is helping
stay-at-home moms with resources and
tips and self-care how can you
that into profit Shelton would you be
able to give us answer in that
yeah for sure I mean helping
stay-at-home moms with self-care my
initial thought would be affiliate
marketing you know I would make a list
right now of what are your favorite
self-care products and man when I think
about mine I think about you know my
bubble bath I'm about my lotions and my
skincare I'm trying to think of what my
wife Sony actually uses because I don't
really have many self care products that
I can think of but you would right you
wouldn't naturally think of how would
you pamper yourself what are some of the
things this could be okay so I got some
I'm looking at for cymatics sale right
now which does like Chonga mushroom
replacement for coffee good for sleep
good for rest for sig Matic if you've
ever heard of that brand they have an
affiliate program I have been I don't
even know the human Noomi Noomi
electrolyte drinks I use the rest the
rest one and the tumeric one and you
could spy those online anything they
sell on Amazon so this is true for
everybody watching you want to think
about how to monetize what are just the
products you love and use and then you
make a video like my nightly self-care
routine and you go a couple things I do
I take a bath and you you're like I like
to use CBD bath bombs from Seoul CBD we
just had a guest speaker who has helped
do a lot of the website this is our
friend's brand could direct to consumer
brand called Seoul CBD and so they've
got CBD bath bombs and so you know you
might be like a rejuvenating way of
natural ingredients to watch the stress
away get relief get smooth get chill get
it on okay okay here we go
and so really good marketing here but
look you go affiliates and now you can
be an affiliate which means when you
recommend a product like this you'll
probably get I don't know what they'll
give you but maybe 15 20 30 % and so on
a $10 bath bomb you can make $3 so if
you just say
what I do before bed is I make myself
some hot cocoa maybe that's just a tip
and then you're like and then I like to
talk up to get Beth and I love using CBD
so bath bombs boom link in the
description if you want to check that
out and then you might recommend another
thing I like listen to my favorite
playlist share link in the description
to a Spotify playlist free value I put
at that playlist on Apple music and
Spotify in case you want to listen to my
relaxation playlist and then I really
also like to use this particular sleep
mask because it really helps me blackout
light and it feels good on my face and
it doesn't cause wrinkles and whatever
and I got that on Amazon so they
directly correlate to products you love
and use already for self-care so it's
it's pretty linear there and that's true
for all of us y'all like affiliate
marketing which by the way if you
haven't subscribed to the think
marketing podcast and even here or if
you happen to be watching on the youtube
channel today's episode we have a
two-part series going out if you want to
learn more about everything I was just
talking about that's today's episode is
all on getting started with affiliate
marketing step-by-step and that's also
on Google
Spotify all the places and so affiliate
that's why I love affiliate marketing
because here's the summary affiliate
marketing is simply getting paid a
commission when you recommend products
you already love and use it's the
cameras and lenses we already love and
use so microphones we already love and
use it's the software we already love
and use we test it and we also say oh
don't use this one get this one instead
right it's like oh a void this odda g7x
mark 3 mana autofocus it's really not
that good I probably stick with them r2
and it's cheaper as well and you're just
a guide you're a helper affiliate
marketing doesn't make the product costs
any additional money so really this is
how content creators can make a living
because the viewer gets to learn about
something and find something awesome and
they're gonna pay that full price
anyways but you get cut in on it so you
can pay your bills it's a win for the
company it's a win for the viewer and
it's a win for you as the content
creator and you can build that out and
scale it and by the way of
course we go into like we go into a
couple different ways on that free
master class to make money in affiliate
marketing is just one of them I think
master class comm but but that's
definitely one of the best ways to get
started and you have to like create
anything or make your own product you
can just jump right in with the stuff
you love and use it Sean going off of
the topic of affiliate marketing ad and
I as well as a couple of other people
are asking some specifics with giving
call-to-action off of your YouTube video
so off of the YouTube platform so
Heather could you illuminate a little
bit of what the balance is with telling
people to go subscribe to an email list
or to go purchase a product through an
affiliate link yeah really great
question and you know this is something
that is it has been a strategy that we
have definitely been changing over the
years as YouTube the platform has been
changing now here's the thing about all
platforms you want to play the game of
the platform to win on the platform and
so YouTube minutes matter most as they
do with all platforms Facebook and
Instagram they want to keep you there
and so the reason they want to keep you
there is because people are spending ad
dollars to get in front of you and so
the more time that you spend on the
platform the more ads that they can show
you on the platform now what does that
do for you as a creator well here's a
couple things we recommend to create bin
jabal content and you want to create bin
jabal content because video is like a
handshake video allows you to get to
know people video allows people to get
to know you it allows them to know like
and trust you more and more and more and
so how many times do you send someone
off the platform we actually now do
about an 8020 we've send people off the
platform about 20% of the time but we
keep them on about 80% of the time and
we are always giving calls to action
every video has a call to action it's
either to watch another video it's that
the links are in the description for the
gear that we're talking about or the
software we're talking about or the free
class that we're talking about whatever
that looks like we're always giving a
call to action
but we really make an emphasis on it
about 20% of the time so we're always
saying links are in the description
below if you're interested but we really
give an emphasis of like go check out
this master class and the reason for
that is what XY and Z or go download
this free thing because of XY and Z
about 20% of the time because we want to
keep people on the platform and here's
the thing your viewers are smart like
think about you as a consumer do you
watch one video and then go and download
something and then go right into
someone's program and go right into
buying a product from someone usually
you want to do your research usually if
you're gonna spend money with a company
or buy something you've probably done
some type of research around that and so
we want to give you ample opportunity to
be able to click away but we also want
to make sure that you have enough videos
to binge-watch that you've already made
a buying decision before you even click
that link because just clicking on the
link doesn't help it's actually going
through making that buying decision so
you want to create bin jabal content
that allows people to know that they
have an opportunity to leave a platform
but about 20% of the time you want to
actually give them more reference to it
so that they know that that is their
next right step so we're having done
that here inside of this video if you've
seen how Sean's been slowly adding
things in it's not like the whole video
is based around the call to actions that
we've given but we've definitely said
some call to actions and if today was
the day that you've now watched 20
videos of ours and you're like you know
what I actually do need to go watch that
master class then you're probably gonna
click on that link and go watch the
master class so I hope that helps and
gives you some some reference as to what
that looks like but you want to play the
game of the platform and minutes matter
most on all platforms yes so good and
the key that Heather is saying there is
that this will apply across all of these
different questions its how do I you
know when do I give people a CTA to my
email list or to my affiliate link or to
really anything is you do want to keep
people on the platform about 80 percent
of the time and then 20 percent of the
time you're giving those CTAs so for the
different variations of that it still
applies and prioritizing value to your
customers so you're always delivering
value they don't have to you know every
single video they don't have to go
somewhere else in order to get the last
point or to finish the tutorial that
you're giving them deliver value upfront
and then will be able to see it in those
CTA s afterwards
all right Sean I have a question for you
from Elba about live streaming and how
you can engage with your audience during
a live stream
love the question Elva and it's so great
to see you here and there's a couple
different ways you know I think that I
guess it may be kind of one-sided
but when you start out you want to make
sure you're giving engagement call to
actions during the video at the very
beginning of this I you hear me say
you're getting value can you lightly
press the like button on whichever
platform you're viewing this on and that
actually isn't a request
straight from my heart could you lightly
press the like button if you're being it
value today that's an engagement signal
I think here's the power tip Elba is
we've questions throughout your content
and not like just set the question of
the day and so ways to do that is to say
have you ever can you relate to this
have you felt that way before
you know and you might have three tips
but you're like yeah the first one is
whatever and then you go a view can you
relate to that or if you felt that way
or let me know have you started your
YouTube channel yet D what is your value
proposition so multiple questions can
create layers of engagement throughout
the video and then there's also the last
tip would be to actually acknowledge
individuals by doing a Q&A like this I
mean I'm talking to you l but like we're
here so this is actually a high level of
a touch point we wish we could answer
everybody's question but of course we do
these q and A's weekly a couple of days
later this week I'm doing coffee with
Cannell which is where I actually bring
you on and then you know there's a few
other places we do Q&A but it's
different things like that I mean I see
Airy hook saying lightly press the like
button over on Facebook and I see pamela
saying be proud she even posted so
acknowledging people i think calling
people out and and doing your best to
create those connections and I think we
just listed out a few other tips there
you could start a Q&A show where you
bring people on like coffee with Cannell
you could start a Q&A show like this you
could answer questions just at the end
and then some of you might be worrying
but you're like but there's not a ton of
people there when you're just starting I
recommend going live practicing in
public
punching fear in the face and using your
season in obscurity listen to prepare
you for popularity
like use your season when no one's there
to practice in public and get better and
get used to live streaming and stumble
and you might say Shawn like man when I
look at Heather or when I look at Mel
like they just seem so confident video
they weren't always like that Shawn I
wasn't always like that on video um I
just did it a lot like a lot a lot like
a lot of embarrassing you know not
confident not clear and even before
video started someone asked me other day
how did you grow as a communicator I
said put yourself in high-pressure
communication situations back in 2009 I
started my business I went to Chamber of
Commerce and they said everybody go
around the room and tell everybody else
what you do and I was like Oh what what
are we gonna do with this Chamber of
Commerce meeting and I just stand up and
when you think about your clear and
concise and compelling value proposition
I assuredly did not have that but I've
been working at in practicing on it so
anyways those are some thoughts invite
people to engage and then just practice
if you're afraid of live-streaming I
encourage you to try it because you're
uncomfortable and awkward livestreams
today and over the next couple months
listen or preparing you for 2022 when
you can't afford not to livestream if
you start preparing today for tomorrow
come on it's it's so critical please
don't I mean I hate to even bring this
up but it's true what about the pandemic
that's gonna happen in 2023 and maybe
one won't but what about the pandemic
that's gonna happen in 2026 for all of
us that are living through this moment
right now if you are hearing my words
and you're paying attention what's
happening in the world and you're
learning the lessons that we're learning
in this season I'm gonna be hardcore
it's your fault if you're not ready for
the next thing that happens in 2025 it's
on you you might have been blindsided by
this one I was blindsided by the
recession back in 2009 my wife and I we
got crushed got houses over leveraged
her health was falling apart our
finances were falling apart we're losing
jobs different things were happening and
I now a decade later have been preparing
for a decade positioning for
decade learning for a decade skilling up
for a decade and this pandemic came it's
almost like I've been learning how to
swim for ten years not realizing the
world was gonna get flooded yeah and at
the think media team we all have so
knowing that the world's may mean get
flooded again cuz guess what it will
build an ark prepared today for the
harvest that you want to reap tomorrow I
know that's some deep that you're like
dude it's got a little deep bro chill
out like but but you get what I'm saying
skill up now start practicing live
streaming now for the one person that's
there which is your husband watching in
the other room or like your sister cool
skill up now because you got to do it
now so that in 2023
you're like dude I'm feeling it now I'm
comfortable now I'm like Heather
tourists now my friends when I met
Heather tourists she was not good on
video she was not who she is today
Melissa you could go back three months
and Melissa Caputo didn't have the
confidence and leadership and I've been
throwing these people in the fire cuz
how did I learn I pressed record
awkwardly and I said I wasn't gonna be
energetic or entertaining but thank God
I did because I didn't realize that
these were gonna become critical skills
YouTube live streaming video I know that
was kind of a rabbit trail there but I
think it's really important friends and
that's what our passion is that's what
think marketing and think media is all
about is because we really want you to
be positioned guarded as recession-proof
is profit possible as position with
whatever business you have or whatever
business you're pivoting into mm-hmm
these are the new one-on-one skills
live-streaming social digital marketing
it's critical and we're here to help I
think Shawn I think that is a worthwhile
deep tangent for sure because it is so
important and we had somebody asking in
the comments is it too late to start
YouTube no no it's not let's start now
and and that's what Shawn is trying to
convey to us right now is that you know
we we need to be jumping in right now
now is
time this is the moment of opportunity
for you guys to get started especially
and things like live streaming so if
you're walking away with this feeling
like I'm not ready I I missed my
opportunity I miss my chance
no that is completely wrong now is the
perfect time to get started and you want
to start now you want to start today as
Sean said while you can practice and get
those reps in before you have a bunch of
eyeballs on you
so start get it started now I can't
emphasize that more I just want
everybody who is questioning that in the
chat to know it is time to start Ana
Sean said I only just started getting on
these live streams a couple months ago
and it was not comfortable it still
isn't the most comfortable for me but
just doing it over and over and over
again I'm so grateful that Sean pushed
me into it
months ago so let him push you into it
too right now and get started I just had
to tack on my little speech there to
John because I feel I'm in it I am in it
right now learning with you guys and
trying to build that confidence so
mm-hmm
and a real quick Mill Katherine just
said well what platform should I
practice live-streaming on practice on
the platform that is available so here's
what I did when I first started on video
like Sean said there was no way I was
gonna get on video but I knew it was a
skill that I needed because I wanted to
be able to speak on stages I knew I had
a message inside of me that I wanted to
get out into the world I knew I wanted
to have a digital business I knew that
these things that I wanted meant that
the obstacle I needed to overcome was
getting over my stage fright was getting
over speaking to a camera was getting
over how I looked or how awkward I sound
you know when you start listening to
yourself on video you're like do I sound
like that is that my voice it's so weird
but what I started to do was I opened up
snapchat back in the day when snapchat
was a thing I guess it's still a thing
but that's where I started and so I
recommend where to go life first go live
on Instagram why it deletes in 24 hours
that's the best place to go someone else
said should I enlist the video once I go
live up to you but here's what you're
gonna need to do you're going to
practice a thousand times you're going
to need to go live
you're gonna get a mess up you're gonna
need to stumble through it you're gonna
need to sweat from your pits like it's
all got to happen and that's part of the
process okay so as you're thinking where
do I go live what do I do
pick a platform and go live that's what
I want you to do because unless you get
those first 1,000 under your belt when
20 23 happens when someone wants you to
be on their podcast when someone wants
you to help them do something and it
requires you to go live you're gonna be
ready you're gonna flip on the camera
you're gonna put the makeup on and
you're gonna go because you're ready for
it so that's what I want you to do
Katherine I want you to get on a
platform and just go live amen thank you
like I should have like a good ending
after that Mel but I just felt fired up
because I knew that question that is
where you start to think about those
little well where do I go live and how
long and what topic and all that those
are distracting you from actually just
going live what could you talk about
with a friend
what are five things what like think
about the easy content that comes
rolling off the tongue all the time for
you and that's what you want to do for
your first live streams just go live if
you go back and look at my stuff oh my
gosh on your right there this was not
Heather on a live stream my voice was
high I didn't even want to look at the
camera I'm like looking away the whole
time it's just part of the process but
until you start to get more comfortable
you won't actually be ready we say like
the Oprah effect like what if Oprah
called like you know what I mean are you
ready that's what we want you to start
skilling up in and live-streaming listen
lean in it's not going away this is not
going away this is just starting Sean
you had a stat about zoom right was it
about zoom that's happening right now
live-streaming is just getting started
so be a forward thinker and get yourself
in the game zoom Airlines if you saw
this is now worth more than the 7
biggest airlines and this may have
pivoted a little because I think travel
is rebounding but it nevertheless the
principles are the same can you believe
that zoom communications the live
streaming
you know teleconferencing software rose
to a 48 billion dollar market
app whereas Southwest Delta United in
the top seven largest airlines dropped
to 46 million this is the sign of the
times like this is it this is the
picture of where's the future it doesn't
mean by the way it doesn't mean that
travel will stop forever and it doesn't
mean any of that it means that what's
here now is live streaming is figuring
out online coaching online connecting
online meetings mastering video
mastering being on camera setting up
your battle station setting up your
streaming station figuring out your USB
mic figuring out your lighting and
before worrying about any of that going
live on just your phone come on these
are the now skills and I'm so glad you
brought that up Heather is it just it's
such a picture of the times and what
we're living through is also the hybrid
where is what we're not going back to I
thank God we're gonna it open up again I
mean we're going to restaurants half the
tables are X tau toh so the hybrid is
it's not either/or it's both and now
it's that every smart entrepreneur and
business owner and creator is gonna be
thinking about both if not the only
online about how is it that I have an
online offer am I gonna write a book am
I gonna have an online course am I gonna
do some kind of e-commerce am I gonna do
affiliate marketing what are you gonna
do and if you haven't figured out what
fits in yet figure out a way to fit it
in because that's how you produce legacy
that's how you protect your family
that's how you position yourself for
where the future is going because for
sure they'll be future shutdowns will be
future disruption it's its diversity
you're diversifying your income streams
you're diversifying your possibilities
you're diversifying your ability to
pivot you're preparing today for
tomorrow and for what may come so good
well so we have a couple more questions
we're gonna jump into here before we to
the top of the hour Heather because you
mentioned in our circle we had some
questions coming in about it so could
you just tell us who inner circle is for
and if it's good for people who are just
starting out on YouTube yeah so here I
think media we have a couple different
programs where we can help you through
your journey of online video and online
business and Shawn and I both come with
over
decade of experience when it comes to
starting online businesses and growing
online businesses we've been able to
grow think media the channel itself -
over a million subscribers it's think
media the company is a multi
seven-figure company and so we had so
many questions coming in beyond just
YouTube so how do you grow a business
around your YouTube channel or how do
you use YouTube to leverage your current
business maybe you already have like a
yoga studio or maybe you already are a
dog trainer maybe you already have an
existing business but you want to figure
out how do I make this happen online
like Sean just said it's that hybrid
model so how are you able to bring your
business online and what are the skills
that you need things like do you have a
funnel built an online funnel do you
have a way to sell something online do
you understand the significance of the
five videos that you need in your
business right now those are the things
that we teach inside of inner circle so
who is it for it's for purpose driven
entrepreneurs it's for content creators
who are business minded it's for people
who want to understand how do i leverage
online like all the online things to
grow a business and so we have this as a
monthly program that you can join at any
time and it is a month's month program
today we actually did a session with we
bring in industry experts as well and
today we had one of our friends come in
and he taught a fire session about
understanding your positioning we talked
about it today value proposition but who
are you and who do you serve is so
important in business and standing out
and so inner circle is for you and if
you are just starting and you want to
understand online business and it's for
you if you currently have a YouTube
channel and you want to understand how
do I build a business around that and
you can go to think inner circle com to
get more details or you can send us an
email at hello at Shawn channel but we
have a lot of different programs here I
think media because we want to serve you
at all the stages in business that
you're at so we have not just inner
circle but we have built out video rank
and Academy which is a signature program
it helps you with YouTube we do a think
take with Shawn that helps you get his
eyeballs on your channel and we also
have a mastermind
so if you're at a higher level in
business and you want our eyes and our
strategy directly on your business we
have that option for you as well so
that's just a plate of what we have
built out here I think media but that's
who inner circle is for and we'd be
excited to have you inside of our circle
community know it's a go fan I see fam
that's right yeah I see crew that's
right I see care yeah thank you for
explaining all of that Heather I know we
have a lot going on here at think media
and so if you guys have any questions
about that just like Heather said we
have a lot of resources for you
including talk withing calm or you can
even just text us your questions and
we'll be able to respond really quickly
to those so Thank You Heather for out
Lightning all of that I have one last
question
Shawn if you can end us strong I know
that you're gonna have some some good
thoughts on this one because this is
something we talk about all the time
here at think media and this is from his
you saying influence and business are
they two different things
hmm man I've been accused of being
long-winded so I'll try to be concise
here but our influence of business two
different things
absolutely influence a business or two
different things there's how I think
about them influencer in general well
let me actually then define oh define
the two terms but do the statement I
think that if you don't have influence
you'll never be successful business
that's kind of how they're connected
think about it there's how we think
about influence John Maxwell we read a
lot of John Maxwell leadership books and
he says leadership is just influenced
nothing more nothing less about
leadership isn't is influence it means
somebody knows you listen right now more
than ever before in a noisy crowded
world Internet YouTube you got to be
known you got to blow up your brand you
got to get in front of people you got to
get discovered that's what our
masterclass is all about is how do you
use YouTube as the second largest search
engine in the world to get discovered
how do you get known and and so that's
influencer
how can anybody follow you if they don't
know you you know you at some point we
we talk about influence leads to income
leads to impact you can't make money if
you have zero followers cuz they don't
even know what you're doing you're not
getting used for YouTube ads you're not
right and then you actually can't make
an impact if you get evicted in a couple
you know in a month because you're not
able to fund the mission so really
influences where I think everything
starts again a business that is not
known will not sell any products or
services so influence to me means a
couple things it's the ability to just
get someone to take an action and they
can't you can't get someone to take an
action if they are not even hearing you
speak that's learning to master social
media you're we're talking about YouTube
and social media about getting the
chance to get in front of somebody to
actually share a message with them you
know we have the best digital paid
traffic strategist I believe in the
world Heather Taurus and I mean it's
crazy because some of the biggest people
in our space are like blown away by the
results she gets with Facebook Ads
Google Ads YouTube ads we're living
through an era where which is seems kind
of a more advanced thing but for a lot
of the entrepreneurs watching this like
you got to be doing if you're not
investing money as a business owner in
digital advertising and we're gonna be
covering that topic on one of these
future q and a's - she just got crazy
results for a dentist got them more
business in basically one week then they
get in like a whole month or a couple
months because of leveraging facebook a
dentist right so listen influencer it's
knowing how do I actually get in front
of somebody pastors nonprofits how do
you actually even get someone's
attention first how do you actually get
in front of them and then you have a
chance to say do you connect with this
message do you want to go further in
some cases I might not be right for
everybody like hey like I some I've done
YouTube ads right and I say hey do you
want to grow your influence on YouTube
if not skip this ad you may not want
like I'm not here to help you get
six-pack abs because like you don't want
to see this but
like it's not the best like it's not not
to see I got the one pack AB like I
could help you get that which is called
don't do sit-ups or lift weights ever
you know so but what I can't help you
with is YouTube like hey do you want
help with YouTube
if not then you know I don't know do
something else let's go play Last of Us
- come on
Final Fantasy 7 remake whatever like
what is it you help people with
influence getting their attention and
then getting the chance to enroll them
in your mission your vision and that's
what leadership is when someone actually
says you know what I want to follow you
and I follow people I follow people on
Instagram for inspiration I follow
people on YouTube for news I follow
people on YouTube for yoga videos for
when I'm about to run and I do yoga for
runners I follow people on YouTube for
reviews on cameras and Macs and apps and
things so I can stay educated right I
follow people on YouTube for final
fantasy 7 material Metiria upgrade
situations because that solves a
particular problem they actually have
influence in my life and I don't look to
the Final Fantasy 7 channel for
spiritual guidance him help like I
follow leaders and pastors and
entrepreneurs and different people on
YouTube
so that's influence and then business is
simply the process of solving a problem
for a profit it means that you have just
used to have some kind of problem for a
profit you sell a product or a service
and for if you're watching this I would
say you might be brand new to this stuff
but I think if just by you being here
your your business minded you feel a
call to entrepreneurship or maybe you've
been an entrepreneur or you're trying to
figure out how to do a side hustle we're
living in an era I'm so passionate about
this because nothing is guaranteed the
jobs that we think are guaranteed the
you know the way college if you go
through college you hope to get a job
like we're really living in an era where
the person that is going to determine
whether or not you have a future is you
like owning I believe that actually
everybody needs to become an
entrepreneur or an intrapreneur meaning
you've got to become creative
you've got to find ways to make yourself
more valuable so that you can not only
potentially keep your position at your
company but you understand a diverse set
of skill sets so you can pivot through a
crazy world where whole industries all
of a sudden a pandemic shuts down and
all of a sudden you need to be able to
do something else a new set of skills
so therefore in my opinion not
everyone's gonna be a business owner I
think that you can run a youtube channel
have a side hustle do different things
meaning you might not have a huge team
or any team at all
great no big deal like different paths
for each of us but I'm serious about I
think every single one of us need to
learn business skills entrepreneur
skills and kind of that's a little rant
I guess on our business and influence
the same thing I think they can be very
very connected I think they also could
be separated but that's a little bit of
a rant on both of those I don't know if
that was valuable Heather amel yes
definitely and I know that there are a
lot of questions we weren't able to get
to today but just want to remind you
guys that we do these streams on a
regular basis and so if you are
connected with us on Shawn's Facebook
page on things or on our other social
media we always let you know when these
live streams are happening we also ask a
lot of we give you a lot of
opportunities to ask your questions on
our social media platforms and so I'm
connect with us there we want to be here
for you guys and I know when Shawn was
talking about pushing me to go live a
lot of people in the comments were like
oh you're lucky you have somebody like
Shawn as your boss and you have somebody
like Shawn to make you do these things
listen Shawn is speaking to you right
now telling you to do these things to go
live to punch you in the face and so yes
I am very grateful to be in this
position but we are also here with you
you're here in our community and leave
today do what Heather said go stream on
a platform just pick one and stream and
then let us know post on Instagram post
on Twitter and tag us at Shawn channel
and he's there he'll see you and we'll
be able to encourage you and go on that
journey with you so I just want to let
you guys know this is not a one-stop
shop YouTube livestream right now this
is a community
we want to be building with you guys so
I hope to see you on on those other
platforms